just going back to Legally Blonde there  was a thing last year you must when it  hit the headlines President Trump he  made the commencement speech yeah and  then it turned out it or what a strong  resemblance to Elle's  graduation speech it was all over the  internet now is yeah maybe a son Jimmy  yeah if you haven't seen it it's sort of  unbelievable we'll just show them the  thing that we take our next steps into  the world you must go forth into the  world it is with passion passion courage  of conviction courage in your  convictions in strong sense of self be  true to yourself  [Applause]  no I always pull down YouTube rabbit  holes and I missed that it's true he is  better when he sticks to the script know  how that happened there were DZ just a  fan of the film is just a big fan  you  [Music]